Writing,
reading,
typing,
texting.
Written language is just one of those things that's always been around.
It's a natural way for you to use words.
It's a given,
but there is something you've forgotten.
It's understandable after all,
it's been a very long time.
Okay?
A long time since no one on the planet knew how to write.
Our story starts with the legend,
the tale of thought.
No,
that's not a list.
Beer hearing,
soften,
feminist south and Thalamus after the Egyptian God,
thoughts and Vince writing,
he runs to Kink,
famous to share this discovery,
but to his Chagrin,
the king isn't impressed at all.
Looking down his nose,
he starts pontificating on the destructive power of this new fangled technology.
Oh,
clever thought.
This invention will produce forgetfulness in the minds of learners with the
neglect of their memory because their trust and writing comes from strange
external marks and not their own internal recall.
The drug you've discovered isn't a memory enhancer,
but I'm mentioning enhancer and you're offering students pretend wisdom not
truth.
This sounds strange.
It's easy for you and your world full of writing to dismiss [inaudible],
but here I'm out.
He brings you back to the early days of writing when it was the hot new thing
and like many other inventions,
not everyone was on board.
Okay,
so let's say for the sake of argument,
you don't want writing.
What are the alternative technologies?
You could bust out your advocacies.
They'll help with counting and doing complex calculations.
Maybe you prefer icons,
ritualized images that help you relate to culturally significant figures,
event and attitudes.
The Keith who is an amazing ink and information storage system using courts
colors and not,
oh,
and don't overlook rope memorization.
Basic option,
sure,
but it's really useful in preliterate societies were sentences can be memorized
and recited by the thousands.
You're brain is bigger than you think.
Perhaps you prefer a petroglyphs rock carvings with major cultural ties that may
refer to nearby places or animals.
Ooh,
watch out writing.
We're getting uncomfortably close.
All of these inventions helped humans keep track of their thoughts.
So what makes writing different?
What's them as afraid of?
Let's talk some ness embeddedness.
These things are all embedded in minds.
Tasks,
rituals,
events,
cultures.
Rip Them from those contexts and you ripped out their expressive heart thoughts.
Drug doesn't come with so many strings attached.
It will DM bed you letting you record any specific thoughts and letting future
generations read it in any context.
So human was famous,
right?
Is writing an unnatural intrusion or do you want to swallow thoughts,
pill and see for yourself what we actually unleashed when we invented writing?
Ooh.